foreign
welcome to next 2022 session on document
AI I'm sadhira van Guri and I lead the
document AI product Suite here at Google
Cloud
today I'm also joined by the managing
director and the head of document
lifecycle at Commerce Bank Andreas
Goldman
we have some new exciting announcements
for you today in the document AI product
Suite so let's Dive Right In
modern economies businesses and
livelihoods depend on digital documents
digital manual labor comprises the work
that many of us do but almost never
shows up in a job description
it is essential to the vast majority of
today's business workflows and it
captures the value of the data in those
digital documents
why AIML for documents
employee experience significantly lower
TCO from automation of manual work
speed and error reduction are some of
the reasons why our customers have told
us they have tried to automate tedious
manual processes with AIML
the reason why Legacy Technologies
require supporting labor manual labor is
because understanding a document is much
more than reading a document
that's where document AI comes in
so let's talk about how we want to help
our customers and their employees manage
the toil of digital manual labor
document AI in a nutshell converts
unstructured content into business ready
structured data
with document AI we have made it our
goal to turn documents into business
ready structure data
as we work closely with our leading
customers we realize that part of the
problem is that Legacy Technologies are
solving a problem that's too simple
yes you can get some structured data
with a table parser but we have heard
that what customers are really looking
for is business ready structure data in
other words they're looking for a
technology that will read documents in
ways similar to humans they are looking
for the confidence that when they start
to automate processes they are not
signing themselves up to different kind
of digital manual labor
Google's document AI presents a simple
and cost effective path to build
documentary AI processors and a
complementary system of record to manage
documents and data
today we're announcing document AI
workbench in public preview
document AI workbench enables you to
automate document processing by using
your own data to build models with
document ai's machine learning platform
powered by state-of-the-art computer
vision natural language and neural
networks
with Tokyo workbench you can use your
data to create ml models for many
document types such as printed scan
handwritten tabular Etc you can label
with a simple interface you can train
for free at the click of a button you
can reduce your time to Market all while
owning your own data within your own gcp
project
you can import already labeled documents
and you have two training options you
can train from scratch to create a model
of any document type you can also
uptrend to get accurate results faster
for document types which have a relevant
processor already that you can use as
starting point such as the invoice
processor
BBVA had this to say about the dockyard
workbench and several other customers
have been going the same sentiment
another customer in libyo has uptrained
an invoice processor with 1600 documents
and increased that F1 score from 75 to
83 thanks to our training documentar
results now beat the results of a
competitor and this will also help Libya
save 20 on the overall cost in the long
run
Sears estimates that their time to
Market will reduce by 80 percent with
dock AI workbench versus building custom
models
Google's Docker workbench offers a
flexible and easy to use interface with
end-to-end functionality for pandera's
clients demands and custom document
extractors and classifiers not only
reduce their prototyping from months to
weeks but also offer
Pandora's clients added cost reductions
compared to their current Technologies
now work which extracted data from
documents more accurately and with less
training data for flexible document
types flexible layout document types
like w9w2 variants and three layout
document types like invoices receipts
bank statements and pay stems a
third-party Agency use dock ai's
workbench alongside major competitors
products to automate this document
processing
here are some of the notable features we
are launching as part of the dock AI
workbench announcement today Nokia
workbench covers essential workflows to
develop custom document extraction
processors within end-to-end UI support
data import schema creation and
annotation training and up training
evaluation and troubleshooting model
deployment and version management
and a human in the loop integration for
Last Mile quality assurance
we also have various Partners available
to help our customers with document AI
in addition to workbench dock AI has
pre-trained processors on documents that
matter to you delivering highly accurate
data and lowering your processing costs
dramatically
over the past year we have improved our
existing dockier for procurement GA
offerings and launch new preview
offerings these improvements span across
processing of invoices receipts purchase
orders we added support for more than
six new languages and expanded to new
regions
today we're announcing the following for
document AI for procurement a ga
refreshed of the invoice and expense
free training processors with
improvements to normalization and line
item entity detection
we're also launching up training in
public preview for invoices expenses
purchase order pre-trained parsers this
will unlock new possibilities for
improving accuracy adding new language
support and customizing the schema
we will also introduce support for five
new languages and expand the
availability of dock AI for procurement
to Canada and Australia
a training for invoice expense and
purchase order featuring process unlocks
new possibilities as I said for accuracy
language support and customization here
is an example of an invoice of training
use case where we have used a training
to improve the results of the invoice
processing
here's another example of where a
training was used to train an expense
pre-trained processor to add a new
language support such as Japanese
today we're also excited to announce ID
document proofing as part of our dock AI
for identity products week
you can also upgrade pre-trained
processes to meet your needs across a
wide variety of pre-trained processors
such as the invoice expense purchase
order contract so on and so forth
in addition to a pre-trained processor
product Suite as well as the workbench
doc AI also has our state-of-the-art
much-loved doc AI OCR comp parser as
well as document split of features that
enables customers to convert their
unstructured documents into text and
structured data
dock AI OCR is able to do just fine with
text however as a developer this would
be very difficult to sometimes integrate
into an application or a storage system
so here were the form parser we're able
to get back a set of key value Pairs and
the layout structure really implies that
there is a question and answer Dynamic
for the content in the document with a
parse key value pair this is much easier
for a developer to integrate into
another system
with that I'm excited to announce
Andreas Walmart the managing director of
document life cycles at Commerce Bank
Commerce Bank has used document AI to
transform their document process
automation systems and I'm excited to
hear more from Andreas over to you
hello everyone
is the second largest private bank in
Germany
it is a leading bank for the so-called
German middle front which is the
majority of corporate blinds in Germany
and a strong partner for approximately
11 million private and small business
customers in Germany with a
client-centric portfolio of financial
services in two segments
we serve our customers in Germany and
globally with approximately 44 000
employees
I am heading the cluster document life
cycle responsible for the document
related services from creation of
documents to archiving as well as the
digital communication to customers
I'm driving in parallel the initiative
paperless Bank in supporting the
transformation of Commerce Bank to a
digital advisory Bank
the dock AI use case is a key initiative
to enable command overall threat
achieved
optimization of the business models to
towards the digital advisory Bank in
combination with a significant reduction
of the number of branches
at the core of the turnaround strategy
new advisory centers are created which
directly depend on this document a
chastion pipeline
as a full service wholesale Bank in the
middle of our transformation we are
still facing a lot of paper-based
communication with our clients
by introducing for example The Advisory
centers we have to redesign the handling
of documents coming in
the new pipeline is relevant for both
segments going forward private clients
and corporate clients
the aim is to automate the recognition
of the incoming documents which was
traditionally done by the staff in the
branches and the backyards
automation via google.ai will allow us
to operate with significantly less staff
Taking Care on sorting and assigning the
documents to the defined business
processes
in summary we are switching from late
scan which means esembler manual
processing and sorting Follow by
Logistics to the back office for
scanning and filing
to early scan which is Central delivery
direct scanning automated sorting and
assigning but okay ipipeline and
followed by the transfer to manual
processing
we talk about approximately 50 million
scanned pages per year and approximately
30 000 incoming letters per day
adding up to a very high number of
document types to be brought on the
pipeline
we will run trained document structured
unstructured freestyle as well as
barcode documents through the pipeline
as a personal benefit it will free us
from our own infrastructure by using a
fully cloud-based model
at the same time we will increase
customer experience by reducing the
running time for incoming documents and
therefore much faster fulfillment of the
requested service for our customers
overall it is helping us to transit to
the digital processes with significantly
higher efficiency
in addition
the new pipeline will allow us a
step-by-step migration of approximately
20 historically drone scanning processes
with a high degree of manual interaction
to the new pipeline within the next
years
not only at Innovation case as well a
renovation case
going forward we will use the same
technology to fully end-to-end automate
high volume processes which will be done
by a partner in cluster into maximum
the nvp will go live soon and we will
then continuously ramp up and retrain to
increase the degree of automation
has established Cloud partnership with
router ranging from infrastructure to
services
we decided to partner with security by
using document workbench due to an
Innovative and future oriented approach
with a strong partner
the covering of a broad spectrum of
documents via different industry as well
as a very comprehensive approach for
custom documents
and we were running a successful proof
of content already in two sounds very
wrong
the first step is achieved and it's
adding value to command spawn
significantly
and going forward documents will
continuously be ramped up to the
pipeline
we are using a customized human inter in
the loop interface to comply with all
our requirements and data sources
meeting the handling as easy as possible
for our back office stuff
nevertheless it is just the beginning
besides ramping up the new pipeline we
have to address the ground process and
document complexity with income ads from
it
based on this we are trying to simplify
those dimensions in parallel to being
able to scale as good as possible
we understand it as a multi-year journey
creating added value with every step for
our customers as well as concerning the
efficiencies in Document Handling and
processing
we are looking forward to realizing the
full potential together with our
partners
thank you for having me today
back to you
thank you Andreas we are very excited to
hear from the customers such as Commerce
Bank how Doc AI has been useful in
furthering their mission and strategy
now on to the next exciting announcement
in the dock AI product suite for today
dock AI Warehouse
now once customers extract data from
documents the next challenge they face
is managing and using this data there
are three challenges today there's no
Cloud native service to store and manage
documents along with its unstructured
data customers need to stitch together
multiple Cloud components
search on unstructured data is very
basic keyword based and complex to
assemble
and building workflows to process
documents requires complex integration
of this extracted data with various
applications and tools
as you can see on the left we have a
mature portfolio to process structured
data however unstructured data
constitutes 80 percent of Enterprise
data and is yet on the third of the
cloud
this product was developed to address
this Gap and unlock value from
unstructured documents
with dockier Warehouse we addressed
three problems with Legacy records
Dr Warehouse provides you the best of
Google semantic search technology on
documents
we've integrated it with best-in-class
Doc AI for scalable and accurate
classification and extraction
and with a cloud native elastic managed
service we manage and scale the compute
storage and databases
Docker Warehouse features span across
search and organization governance and
compliance workflows and Integrations
and Ai and data processing
as you can see doc Warehouse is
applicable to a broad range of use cases
document types and workflows we have
seen initial traction with financial
services Healthcare supply chain
Industries but it's applicable to a
broader set of operational
document-based applications
what we're announcing today is a UI to
administer search browse folder and
govern documents apis
client libraries to manage search
documents folders schemas
self-serve provision from the cloud
console catalog with documentation
and GCS connectors in batch dock AI
pipeline management workflows
that wraps up all our announcements in
the dock AI product Suite today here are
a few ways that you can learn more and
even get Hands-On with Doc AI please get
in touch with us via your Google Cloud
contacts or directly at Doc AI hyphen
external at google.com
thank you again for joining us today and
we look forward to working with you all
on your document related challenges
[Music]